well thank you everybody for coming and
thank you Gisela for inviting me it's a
nice to be here actually the very first
vided talk I gave as a new professor was
here at the Department of Anthropology
when Eric's are just invited me about
six years ago so it's kind of like a
nice since I moved to a new position six
years later it's nice to be here again
reminds me a lot of that time so today
I'm going to be talking about evolution
in the enthronement although with this
crowd I'm sure you're very familiar with
thee the idea of the Anthropocene and in
particular population genomics of New
York City wildlife and how such genomic
patterns are influenced by urbanization
in the city and just to start off I just
wanted to acknowledge at the beginning a
lot of people have helped with this at
CUNY and university of connecticut at
Fordham and also our funding agencies
and a bunch of people in New York City a
bunch of institutions in New York City
that allow us to do this work just to
highlight them at the beginning all
right so you might be wondering why
somebody in New York City would want to
study New York City Wildlife enter
whether there is in fact life in New
York City and there is and what's the
driving factor for for why I became
interested in the evolutionary biology
of urban wildlife well it's really
because if you look at the planet today
the terrestrial surface of the earth you
really don't find too many places that
aren't at least moderately impacted by
human beings and this map here is a map
generated from Earl Alice's data set on
an thromes so he actually and
collaborators rican sep chua lies the
idea biomes these major communities
defined by the types of plants that make
up that community he redefined these
biomes as an thromes as different types
of land use defined by how humans are
using them so if you look at the map of
North America you can easily infer what
is going on in these various places so
we're here in this giant urban to
suburban and from here in the Northeast
and then we have we do have some
forested areas these dark green and
light green although he calls these
residential forest because they have a
fairly high human population
density then you have these these yellow
and beige areas that make up much of the
western part of the country and these
are basically agricultural fields and
pasture lands for primarily for cattle
and the only true wilderness is you know
are places like deserts and very high
elevation and then as you get much
farther north where the human population
density is very low so that's really
what the terrestrial biomes look like
now they're they're very heavily
impacted and maybe even defined by how
humans are using them so that's why I'm
interested in wildlife that live in the
city because so much of our country and
other areas is now this kind of urban
biome so despite this realization there
haven't really been that many ecological
studies conducted in urban areas this
was a recent review that Laura Martin up
at Cornell did where she actually went
through five thousand recent
publications in the leading ecology
journals and she defined what types of
sites they were studying and a full
two-thirds of those five thousand
studies were focusing on protected areas
so the idea is that you go to the area's
least impacted by humans so you can see
the real biology happening in the
absence of humans as a variable but if
that's not really what most of most of
our ecosystems look like maybe we need
to put more effort into areas that
aren't as protected and she found that
there were you know maybe fifteen
percent that were done in agricultural
areas or rangeland areas but only a very
small sliver that we're done in our
human residential area so in dense
settlements or urban or suburban areas
about four percent and this was in
ecology journals if you looked in
evolutionary journals it would be even
fewer than four percent so it seems like
there's there's been a lack of attention
paid to these urban and suburban anthems
so despite the low research interest we
do have some ideas some some basic
general ecological relationships that we
can start with and this is what I moved
to new york city became interested in
this is these are the types of basic
relationships i started to think about
so
terms of biodiversity this model has
been proposed by McKinney back in 2002
for how species richness changes along
an urban to rural gradient so what
happens to wildlife in cities and in
general it's some kind of decline in the
shape of that curve may be a little bit
different depending on the group this
was developed particularly for birds and
he went further along with Blair just
before him and tried to define kind of
like ecological functional categories of
species that use cities so you have a
fairly large set of species that he
called urban avoiders so these are the
types of organisms that really use
forest interior in relatively large
contiguous forest habitats and you can
think about this particularly in the
case of the Northeast because that's
what I'm going to be talking about but
it applies to other places so these ones
you don't really find in urban suburban
areas then you have your urban adapters
and actually by adapter there wasn't
really an evolutionary hypothesis behind
this he meant more in terms of
behavioral flexibility or some other
pre-existing trait that just allowed
them to thrive in these kinds of
habitats so these are species are
typical of suburban environments or city
park environments because city park
environments are somewhat similar and
these are often edge species so species
that like to live that use forest edges
and kind of move in and out and those
are the things that have become very
common in the suburbs are probably in
most parts of kinetic as well you think
about things like white-tailed deer and
turkeys white-footed mice all these
species that can take advantage of those
kind of edge habitats then you have the
urban core and he's that he has a you
know a proposal for how you could define
these using a simple variable so the
urban core would be where you have
greater than fifty percent impervious
surface so where it's mostly roads or
rooftops or some other kind of hard
human-made surface that's not poorest
water and the only species you find
there are your urban exploiters and
these are mostly commensal species often
invasive species that have come along
with humans rats pigeons starlings house
sparrows these are classic urban
exploiters that have probably the
evolved a very tight linked to human
beings so I was particularly interested
in these kinds of species because these
tend to be native wildlife that you'll
still find it in New York City at least
in park-like environments and so this is
kind of the view from urban ecology for
how biodiversity changes and what
informs my work is this kind of parallel
observation that's become more and more
prominent along with the rise of urban
ecology which is the idea that evolution
can happen fairly rapidly so I was
interested in looking at evolutionary
changes within these urban adaptors
these edge species in city parks I
talked a lot of people who sort of you
know where the view no you're not going
to see any change genetically if you see
any changes are just going to have lost
most their genetic variation but
actually there's this emerging view and
it's only become going to become more
prominent in my opinion now that we have
much greater access to genome-wide data
that evolution can actually happen
fairly rapidly and that rapid evolution
might be ubiquitous so it's likely that
these species that are urban adaptors
these species that are living in our new
an Thrones are evolving at least in some
ways and there was a recent review a
book-length review by John Thompson
about rapid evolution called relentless
evolution and he defines rapid as less
than 200 years or a few hundred
generations and these rapid cases often
involve eco evolutionary dynamics which
is basically just this feedback between
the ecology and the evolution so you
have a species that's evolving that's
locally adapting say to an environment
as it locally adapts its better able to
use the resources than environment so
it's changing the ecology also and that
it's changing the ecology for other
species then you get them evolving along
with this so you get this feedback
between ecology evolution and he talks
about both neutral cases of evolution
you know things like genetic drift and
changes in gene flow and then also
adaptive and he makes the point that
most of the adaptive evolution is going
to be standing genetic variation because
these are short timescales there's not a
lot of new mutations there's enough time
for a lot of new mutations to arise and
be swept to
fixation so heat I like this this
phrasing a lot he talks about rapid
evolution is the continual redeployment
of standing genetic variation in
different ways and so thinking about
urban wildlife in thinking about the
possibility of rapid evolution I was
thinking you know is do you see this
happening in urban environments and do
we have much evidence of this there are
some emerging case studies where the
genetics aren't necessarily worked out
but there's some some fairly good
evidence that species are locally
adapting this is a crevice sancta a
small aster flower and this flower
occurs all across the the countryside in
France and in that country side this is
typically how they grow you can see all
those little yellow flowers so it's like
an old field or or a fallow field and
they're just you know spread out
everywhere in these kind of meadow like
environments and they traditionally
produce this kind of seed this like long
tufted seat it's very light and it just
can sort of float away on the wind in
the city and this is particularly in
Marseille and France where these studies
were done by chef tues lab you often
find them in tree pits so these urban
tree pits where you just have a cut in
the sidewalk and there's a small patch
of Earth and there's a tree planted
there so you find this plant growing in
these tree pits and here's this how
they're laid out on the sidewalk very
much like a traditional looks like the
diagram of stepping stone population
genetics model right and it turns out
this this plant can also produce another
type of seed this heavy non dispersing
seat instead of blowing away it just
falls straight to the ground so if
you're growing in this tree pit and
you're producing that tufted seat it's
just going to blow away and probably end
up on the road or the side of a building
and be a dead end but if you're
producing the heavy seed it has the
possibility of falling straight down and
growing so it could be this is just
plasticity but they actually brought the
plant into the greenhouse and they found
that this was a heritable trait the type
of seed that they produce and they've
monitored this population now for a
dozen or 15 generations and they found
every generation a greater percentage
the plants are producing that heavy non
dispersing seeds so they're adaptively
shifting to the other seed type and
actually now they think about it another
recent example gets talked about is
Steve Brady's work which I know I'm sure
a lot of you know from Dave skellies lab
where he showed that there were these
kind of roadside deems of spotted
salamanders that seem adapted to
breeding in roadside ponds versus into
interior for responds that's another
example where the genetics isn't quite
worked out but it's likely that there is
some local adaptation going on there but
just one other very recent example as
Charles Browns work from University of
Tulsa he has been monitoring these cliff
swallow populations for something like
40 years you know they come back to the
same highway overpasses and they build
their mud nests underneath and so he's
been collecting all sorts of data on
these cliff swallows but one thing he's
been doing is picking up birds that have
been run over by cars and measuring
various traits in those birds and what
he's found is that there's been a
persistent trend towards the road kill
birds having the longest wing lengths
and so over time what's happened is that
the the birds of the longest wing legs
have been getting hit by cars at a
higher rate and so the wing length in
the overall population has gone down and
this is almost certainly at least a
partially heritable trait and the reason
for this is just having longer wings
it's as something to do with the
aerodynamics of flight so when they're
coming out and they swooped down they
swooped down further apparently when
they have longer wings they're more at
car level whereas the shorter winged
ones may go over the cars but these long
ones hoop down and then they just get it
by the car so this is you can imagine
there these birds aren't going anywhere
you're just going to have these short
wing colonies of cliff swallows that
have evolved all over the United States
and this is just one colony I'm sure
it's happening in lots of these places
so those are some examples where there's
been a fairly rapid change in a
phenotypic trait that has a heritable
basis due to human behavior
so uh so my work has really aimed to
look at multiple types of evolution so
we initially were interested in genetic
drift and migration or gene flow and how
that's influenced by an urban landscape
so how does the composition of New York
City's landscape change patterns of
genetic drift and migration we've since
gone outside the city and are interested
in overall house how standing genetic
variation so genome wide variation
changes across a gradient of
urbanization so if we start in very
large rural contiguous areas down to the
city just how much standing genetic
variation are you losing if any and the
idea here is background for looking at
signatures of selection on coding
regions in other parts of the genome
that might be involved in adaptations to
urbanization and there is enough staying
generation I'll just give that way but
there are some interesting patterns as
well now before I dove into our results
i also want to just make a few comments
about climate change because this is a
climate change seminar series and i'm
obviously not a climate scientist but i
thought i'd say a few things about it so
one thing one thought i've had this is
as wave may be stimulating discussion
later is that in some ways urbanization
may be a good model for understanding
the evolutionary concepts of climate
change for some species because cities
are already warmed and they have been
for awhile so there may be local
adaptation to these warmer conditions
and cities so this is a some these are
some graphics that nasa generated for
new york city so there's central park
just to orient you and that's manhattan
in the rest of the city and what they
show there's a very tight correlation
between vegetation and the surface
temperature in New York City so here is
the vegetation greener means there's
more vegetation and then here is the
temperature where lighter colors are
hotter and you can see that the cooler
areas are superimposed on top of the
park so there's already this kind of
mosaic of warming happening on local
scales within cities and also at the
city as a whole
is warmed so if we look at warming along
urban gradients you find that the most
warming occurs in that urban core right
and then it it Peters out as you go more
out to the countryside with depending on
exactly what type of have your hat
you're talking about there's going to be
some variation so urbanization might be
kind of a test case of how some species
are going to respond to warming another
possible way in which climate and
urbanization may be interacting
particularly in the Northeast is there's
this idea with climate change that we're
either going to want to help species
move northward to escape their warmed
client they're warmed climates or
they're going to do that on their own or
they're going to be able to evolve to be
in place right but if if some of these
species are going to move northward
they're going to have to get through
urban areas especially here so there
it's not like they're just going to be
encountering a cooler climate as they
move as they slowly move northward as
the climate warms they're going to have
to deal with urban areas so there's
going to be a very clear interaction
there between climate and urbanization
and do we want to try to account for
that now you know fifty or hundred years
out before these species need to make
their slow Trek northward and especially
if we're talking about coastal species
trying to get through that then it's
also possible that urban wildlife or
plants for that matter are not really a
good model for understanding anything
about climate change part of that may
just be because the species that are
already in the city are the sinner bix
pcs that show a positive response to
urbanization and maybe they already had
some pre adapted trait that allows them
to thrive in urban areas regardless of
the temperature and they have some broad
temperature range and are robust to a
bunch of different environmental
variables so maybe they're just not
going to be a clear story here but that
said these sin Arabic species are
important components of communities so
if they're making it in in cities or in
warmed areas than maybe other species
they have some important lessons for
other species or if we build corridor
for them is going to help other species
move along although this is pushback
I've received at other talks have
anything to do with urban corridors or
urban wildlife that maybe we don't want
to do this because what you're doing
with urban corridors is potentially
promoting things that we don't want
that's specifically emerging infectious
diseases all of the tick-borne diseases
raccoon roundworm is an emerging problem
in New York City and things like rabies
which is also a big problem so just some
some thoughts about climate change at
the beginning and what about
evolutionary responses to climate change
so there was just a special issue of the
journal evolutionary applications that
was about this exact topic where they
had multiple chapters on different
taxonomic groups and they assess the
evidence for evolutionary responses to
climate change and there are actually
very few clear examples where species
have adapted already there are more
examples in plants and that's mostly
because they're easier to work with you
can do these greenhouse experiments to
confirm one of the big challenges is
it's very difficult to distinguish
between plastic responses and selection
so a lot of species will be able to
shift their phenotype just through
plasticity under climate change but so
it's not always clear when selection is
the role the other huge issue which is
also a confound in a lot of urban
ecology and evolution is that climate
change its heart is lots of things right
and there's all these other
environmental drivers like urbanization
and other types of land transformation
so it's very hard even if you can show
that selections are going on it's very
hard to identify the exact selection
pressures and whether its climate change
or something else all right so having
said that I want to move back into what
our aims are for our work in New York
City and in our first pass was to get an
idea of genetic drift in migration so
our species in New York City
particularly in parks are native
wildlife and parks experiencing enhanced
genetic drift and are they becoming
different differentiated in a neutral
sense over
I'm and is there still the possibility
of migration through the new york city
landscape and when we came with these
aims we also sort of sat down and
reviewed some of the urban biota in New
York City and tried to come up with the
most likely candidates are the best
models to study and my background was in
mammalogy so I was particularly
interested in small mammals and I have
some collaborators that are particularly
interested in phibian so we decided on
small mammals and salamanders as our
sort of first groups and to give you an
idea of thinking back to that urban
avoider urban adaptor exploiter scenario
these are some candidates for those
categories there are really orbit
explorers on here but these are pretty
typical urban adaptors things that like
forest fragments so the read-back
salamander and white-footed mice these
is going to be basically the same story
around here in much of Connecticut then
you have some that aren't quite urban
adaptors a little more patchy you find
them in some places but not others
things like short-tailed shrews and
metal bowls dusky salamanders and two
line salamanders so they're kind of
intermediate between an avoider and an
adapter and then these are a bunch of
urban avoiders so rare in New York City
means they occur in like one place or
only on Staten Island like a very like
less developed area things like spotted
salamanders and red salamanders and
other kinds of shrews and then just a
whole bunch of other stuff that is gone
from the city and these are typically
things you won't find again until you
get into big protect areas like the
Catskills or something so having
identified some urban adaptors we also
set out to come up with some simple
hypotheses the idea being that most of
these native species are going to be
fragmented and in the populations are
going to be isolated from one another
because these aren't animals that can
just walk down the street like a rat or
a pigeon they do need some form of
natural habitat so the first sort of
classic conservation genetic prediction
would be that fragmented populations
would be experimenting would be
experiencing genetic drift so just
random changes from generation
generation would cause them to diverge
from each other and there are two
possible results of that process genetic
structure where the populations become
different in terms of their low
frequencies over time not an adaptive
sense just randomly and then also that
they'll be losing genetic variation this
doesn't necessarily imply loss of
genetic variation but if the populations
aren't large than you'd expect them to
be losing some of their diversity the
other possibility if they're isolated
and they maintain adequately large
populations with enough starting genetic
variation is that you could have local
adaptation through natural selection and
we came up with a set of a priori otha
sees they have to a density dependence
so one interesting feature of
populations particularly those two
organisms in small urban fragments is
that their populations are very dense so
even though they're in small patches
there's a lot of them and it seems to be
because they're competitors and
predators are gone or highly reduced so
they kind of take over those little
patches so in a density dependent
scenario if they're experiencing you
know generation after generation much
more crowded conditions you might have
selection on low sigh related to disease
and immunity it's very easy to pass
disease in those kind of places anything
having to do with competition for
resources faster life history and even
mating system kind of things like access
to mates wife Adam ice in particular
when they're very crowded conditions can
switch from more of a polygamous mating
system to basically a promiscuous sort
of scramble competition and other
peromyscus have been found to exhibit
sperm selection pretty clearly in some
of those conditions and then you know
density independent effects like
pollution or habitat structure things
that are going to affect all the mice no
matter how crowded the conditions are
elevate these may interact and then sort
of generalize stress response from
living in these in these new
environments with lots of challenges
somos
I want to i'm going to talk about today
in terms of results are from the
white-footed Mouse that's the organism
we work with the most peromyscus
leucippus if you've gone out with the
mammalogy class in college or grad
school this is probably what you've
trapped or it's close relative
peromyscus maniculatus maniculatus just
to be clear this is a native species
it's not house mouse or rat they're
actually not that closely related and as
I mentioned before they have very dense
populations in small fragments so they
show actually a negative relationship
between the area of a front of a patch
that they're in and the density and
again that's because they're probably
being released from competition with
other small mammals or other species and
a lot of their predators are out there
and we initially worked on this one this
species because it occurs in most of the
parts it's very easy to work with very
easy to trap there are already a lot of
genetic resources available so for our
first studies we went out to 15 parks
and sample genetic material from about
25 mice / park and this these green
areas don't actually show the extent of
vegetation they're actually just New
York City parklands which is to give you
an idea of where we trapped in to orient
you number 6 and that green long
rectangle that's always Central Park in
these maps then up here is the Bronx
where there's several large parks in
proximity a little park here the tip of
Manhattan and then there's a number of
parks distributed along the terminal
moraine in in Brooklyn and Queens so
this is where the glacier dumped a bunch
of material as it was receding and you
have this hill and because of that
they're a bunch of parks that were
preserved there and then a couple sort
outliers down here in Jamaica Bay and
for the initial studies we genotyped
those mice at 18 microsatellites and
also sequence the d-loop these are you
know at the time and still today are
sort of classic markers for looking at
genetic structure and in rapid changes
due to drift so we'll be fine in terms
of genk drift the first surprising
result is that these populations were a
lot more structured than we ever thought
they would
so if you're not familiar with this kind
of chart this is a bar plot from from
the program structure and the idea is
that one of these bars is one individual
Mouse's genetic data and one color is an
inferred evolutionary cluster so it's
it's a coherent cluster of individuals
that meet certain expectations and in
this particular analysis you're looking
for clusters that fit hardy-weinberg
equilibrium and linkage equilibrium so
you think back to like hardy-weinberg
from like intro bio that's what we're
talking about here so they're good
neutral populations and what you find is
that for each one of these parks they're
pretty much represented by one color in
a lot of cases so these mice are
differentiated enough that you can
distinguish the mice and Central Park
from Willow Lake in tell them apart and
some of these are so distinct if you
gave us a mouse and we genotyped them at
those same low sigh you could actually
figure out where they were from you'll
also see that there are some that are
more mixed up like these two here and
this one here there's a lot of different
colors kind of messy and those are cases
where we actually are fairly certain
there are good corridors that prevent
the mice from becoming differentiated I
want to make the point that even though
there is this structure the jank
diversity is pretty high it's like 70 90
percent in terms of heterozygosity of
the microsatellite so they aren't they
haven't gone through massive bottlenecks
or anything at least recently this is
just another way of displaying the same
information where we analyze the
populations rather the individuals this
is kind of the relative spatial
orientation of the parks and each one
that's a different color is again a
different evolutionary cluster and you
see these three that are in blue those
are the same that we're all mixed up on
the previous slide turns out they are
connected by an old roadway so this was
the Long Island motor parkway which was
the first toll road on Long Island and
the idea was you pay like a nickel and
you could drive all the way out into
Nassau County but what happened to it is
that Robert Moses built the Grand
Central Parkway which is free which
immediately put this out of business the
guy went bankrupt he gave it to the city
and this is what it looked like for a
long time they just let it basically go
to seed and then eventually they put a
nice bike path in there but on either
side is a secondary force so this is a
clear corridor that these mice just are
distributed along or can move through so
that that prevents those populations
from becoming distinct from each other
so that's a you know a good test case
where you could identify an accidental
corridor that has this result of
preventing genetic drift so some of the
other early results we did detect
bottlenecks but only in a few
populations there was not a
generalizable bottleneck phenomenon
where the these populations crashed due
to urbanization there wasn't really any
evidence of male bias dispersal and the
reason I say the reason I have that is
as significant is that in most
populations of peromyscus leucippus male
bias dispersal has been detected as the
main way you have longer range dispersal
between patches but here there's just
isn't any dispersal or it's very low so
you don't detect male bias dispersal and
basically what all these are scatter
plots are showing is that there's no
relationship between Jack diversity and
a bunch of characteristics of the parks
park size the amount of habitat or how
old the park was we thought that would
give us some idea of a relative levels
of janked diversity but there's no clear
trend and I think that's just because
Janet diversity was relatively high in a
lot of these parks it didn't seem to
matter that much if you're a really
small park or one of the bigger ones in
the city they still had a lot of genetic
diversity so I mentioned that we also
sequenced d-loop haplotypes this is
another marker like microsatellites that
evolves very rapidly and we thought it
would show the basically the same
pattern but it showed this interesting
results where we have this peak in a
mismatch distribution that often
indicates an interesting demographic or
possibly natural selection event so what
this graph here is let's say you've got
all these DNA sequences from the
mitochondrial dilute and you compare
them across individuals and you just
count up the number of base pair
differences beach
the sequences and this is a frequency
distribution of how many differences you
have so here this is for all of New York
City the number of pairwise differences
there's a clear peak around two and then
up there it's about the same although
this one's for all that's just for
Queens that one shifted a little closer
to one so what this indicates is that at
some point the d-loop most of its
variation was wiped out and so all the
sequences are pretty similar and then
over time they're kind of drifting apart
but most of them are only a base pair
different or two base pairs different
from each other and that's a considered
a classic signal of one of these two
things it could be a bottleneck where
you had a bottleneck and the populations
recovering from that and slowly building
up variation again through mutation and
over time if that's the case this is
like a moving wave that goes that way is
number of base pair differences builds
up it could also be when you have a
selective sweep so there's potentially
some so I'll give you a scenario where
you have some particular mitochondrial
haplotype that's favored in an urban
environment that sweeps to fixation then
you just have some neutral mutations
building up again after the sweep how do
you distinguish between those it's
actually pretty difficult that's why
there's a question mark there given that
we didn't find evidence of widespread
bottlenecks in the nuclear data I'm
inclined to think that the demographic
explanation is not as likely but we
don't have a clear answer for why there
would be selection on the mitochondrial
genome although there have been a number
of studies now have found that and
curiously peromyscus leucippus in
chicago show this exact same pattern and
it was inferred there that it was due to
a bottleneck as Luke opus replaced
maniculatus in in Chicago although that
did not happen in New York City it's
there's no evidence that manipulates was
in the city so it was kind of an open
question I'll show you some results
later that provide further evidence for
mitochondrial genes being under
selection in the city but we don't have
a clear answer between those two
hypotheses all right so that those were
our results on genetic drift I mentioned
we were also interested in migration or
gene flow so even though they're
structured where are there still
places where mice can move around the
city can we capture that in a simple
model and then does that model explain
the actual genetic results we see so we
created landscape ecology models of how
mice would move through the city then we
had genetic estimates of the rates of
gene flow between populations and we
trick we wanted to see if those were
correlated and so to do this you need to
have some you need to have a model for
mouse movement that's based on some
ecological variables we tried a number
of different types of land cover data
but what ultimately worked the best was
simply canopy cover an estimate of
canopy cover and I'm not going to say
that canopy cover is the actual
explanatory variable it's probably a
proxy for just vegetation cover in
general so these yellow dots are the
parks we sampled and the tiny little
squares in this map each pixel is a 30
meter by 30 meter square of the city
this is from the National Land cover
database and each square is assigned a
canopy cover from zero to a hundred
percent and this is inferred from remote
sensing data but it's it's been fairly
well ground truth and in the city it's
been ground truth even better because
people have been interested in using it
there are 1 meter by 1 meter data sets
for New York City but the only benefit
to using those is you can find
individual street trees which I don't
think mice are using birds might use
that but this 30 meter data set seemed
pretty good alright so we have that
ecological data set then how do we model
mice or some animal moving through the
landscape the classic population genetic
expectation is that basically animals
move in straight lines from one place to
another and the farther apart those two
places are the longer it's going to take
the animal to move or the harder it's
going to be for them to make that
distance and that's the the population
genetic prediction of isolation by
distance that populations or animals
will be more genetically different from
each other just in a linear relationship
as they get further and further apart
because animals can
move unlimited distances that's not very
satisfying as a biologically realistic
model because most animals don't follow
straight lines especially in a
complicated environment like a city
they're going to be tracking some sort
of preferred habitat or resource so to
try to capture that more of that
complexity we used a recently developed
model called isolation by resistance
it's a implemented in a program called
circuits cape and the idea is you have a
population here in a population here and
instead of them just being separated you
know being separated by that straight
line distance there's this whole
intervening landscape that animals can
move through and you want to find all
the paths and how likely it is the
animals move through those pads so what
the program takes advantage of is
circuit theory from physics and so you
simulate let's say you want to simulate
move them from here to here so you you
plug in an electric source here and
ground it here and then each of your
cells of the landscape those 30 meter by
30 meter grids are linked to each other
by an electrical resistor and you can
set a resistance value for how hard it
is for the electricity to flow through
that resistor and you can set that based
on some ecological prediction so if this
is say a hundred percent canopy cover
but this is eighty percent or fifty
percent you can set a resistance for how
hard is the electricity to go there and
then the electricity starts flowing
through all these resistors and if it
counters very high resistance and just
peters out and that's not a likely path
but if it follows some other path where
it can make it all the way between the
two populations that might be a good
path that animals are using and it turns
out that this circuit theory is
mathematically related to random walk
models in animals which are these kind
of you know you start it's kind of also
called the drunkards walk we start the
animal moving sort of randomly but you
can you can buy us its movements by
changing the landscapes it moves through
so it has some interesting properties so
that's the idea is to find all of the
paths between the populations but you
need to set the resistance values so we
tested a bunch of models for what types
of environments might still be able to
move through
this is a very stringent model where
each of the green squares has at least
ninety percent canopy cover if mice need
at least ninety percent can it be
covered there's not much for them to
move through everything that's gray is
less than that and in this model they
wouldn't be able to use it just don't
you again that central park there that's
an eighty percent model so a little bit
more landscape for them to use seventy
percent and so on so we use these kind
of threshold cut-offs to see if there
was a model if we reached a model where
all of a sudden we were explaining the
actual estimates of genetic migration
really well so there's a ten percent
model so they're at least ten per each
square has at least ten percent can be
cover if they can use that then there's
a lot more green stuff for them to use
to move around in the city just to give
you an idea of the range there between
90 and ten percent so which of these
models or if any explained gene flow it
turns out that once you had around
seventy percent canopy cover all of a
sudden you were explaining most of the
variation gene flow between the
populations and I'm not going to say
that that is like a magic cut off
there's probably some range of
parameters in which they're using but
that gives us somewhere in the ballpark
and this is independent of straight line
distance so it's after factoring out the
effect of just how far the populations
are in a straight line so we were
actually pretty surprised that you could
explain so much variation in gene flow
with a simple variable like this but
ever having talked a lot of people and
read all the simulation studies it seems
that this type of modeling works much
much better in a place like a city than
it does in other environments because
the city environment is so binary it's
so stark from the perspective of
wildlife in a lot of cases because
you'll have yours you know your green
area that they can use and then the
other stuff is so ecologically different
that it acts as a quasi barrier in a
more complex heterogeneous more natural
landscape those it's not as binary it's
not nearly as this the effect is not as
strong so this this kind of analysis
probably works much better in a city
so what do these pads look like and what
are they on the ground so here's a
circuit map for the Bronx and their
central park down there so wherever you
have the lighter colors that's where
it's inferred that the mice will be able
to move that's where the electricity is
flowing through the circuits so here's a
big Park in the Bronx here's a botanical
garden Fordham University campus right
there so what are these what are these
lines of connectivity so if you go
through them some of them are just
linear parks like you've got where they
were green spaces planted and aligned
like a long road Parkway medians
cemeteries riparian areas along streams
that seems to be where we still have
these green areas so for example there's
a big Cemetery between two of those
parks at least part of the way and on
the edges there's still like these
little scrubby forests where you're
probably gonna have lots of wildlife and
they see all sorts of wildlife running
around the graves in the cemetery then
there's a whole series of parkways and
some of them are like this you know
where you just have trees and mowed
grass but some of them are they don't
mow them very often and they get pretty
scrubby and there's probably plenty of
things in there then you have the Bronx
River and a few other waterways where
they didn't develop right down to the
edge so you have secondary forest on
either side and there have been camera
trapping studies have been involved with
where you put them along the Bronx River
on the edge here and all sorts of things
are moving through along those corridors
so that so these seem to be real things
that you could identify in a city all
right so those were our results and that
works mostly done where we looked at
genetic drift in gene flow and as we
started to think about the potential for
a local adaptation and selection
operating these populations we're
interested and as more genomic tools
became available as the study was
progressing we wanted to look at genome
wide variation and how that interacts
with urbanization this is very much
ongoing so the second thing I want to
talk about is this question of whether
genome wide variation is spatially
associated with urban is a
in some clear predictable way and for
this we sampled a 24 populations so we
have our urban populations down here and
then a number of populations along a
gradient verbalization it looks fairly
linear but that wasn't the point the
point was to find an actual grade and
urbanization not necessarily have it be
a straight line so these are your really
urban populations these are like inner
suburban these are outer suburban and
then these are fairly big protected
areas and we we have them on either side
here to possibly represent different
sets of ancestral variation that may
that these populations may be derived
from and we've been using this
relatively new technique which a lot of
you probably heard of from Gisela's lab
this DD rad seek and the idea is instead
of sequencing the whole genome you can
carve up the genome with certain
restriction enzymes and restriction
enzymes cut the genome specific
locations and so if you cut everyone's
Geno every individual in the study's
genome with these enzymes you can select
out fragments of the same size and we'll
be at least some of the same fragments
across all the individuals you can
sequence those fragments and then find
single base pair differences as your
genetic markers and so this study
includes 230 mice from 23 populations
acid 24 but one of the I think one of
those was just one individual from one
site and they were sequenced in three
alumina high seek lanes and in the end
we got about 1.2 billion reads goodreads
of about a hundred base pairs long and
this is very this is preliminary it's
actually fewer than this now if we've
done a lot more work on it but somewhere
in the ballpark of around a hundred
thousand snips sampled in each
population so if we revisit this
question of population structure what do
we find so down here these are all of
our queen urban Queens populations then
our other urban populations are here and
the ruler ones are up here was
interesting that Queen seems to have a
lot more diversity than a lot of the
other places and that's probably because
of the
geography of the situation because you
have long island as this land mass which
Queens is on so there if we separate if
we take these orange dots out this gets
a lot more spread out and you can see
the differences more but Queen seems to
be pretty diverse and different and
we're going to have to probably add some
more Long Island populations understand
what's going on there and if we revisit
these structure plots using subsets of
snips what do we find a lot fewer
clusters which isn't necessarily
surprising because snips evolved a lot
slower than microsatellites so we're
looking at kind of hierarchical
variation here so what is the variation
we got all these populations we got
about five clusters we have a very clear
Long Island component which is the green
so those are those ones that were the
orange dots on the previous pca Central
Park which is pretty much its own thing
which is maybe not surprising again
because it's also on an island and it's
very isolated in the Bronx pretty clear
signature of its own and in the suburban
populations and then these rural
populations that are pretty far out so
that seems to be kind of the next level
of hierarchical variation using that
kind of analysis this is all preliminary
but I wanted to show you one other type
of analysis we're doing with these data
so one thing we're interested in is how
different genetic markers or how this
variation is distributed across a
landscape so think about one snip so one
base for a difference like an a versus a
tee in some genomic position how would
you expect that to how would you expect
the frequency of a versus T to change
across the landscape in different
evolutionary scenarios if it's conserved
let's say you know so in all of these
graphs these are like x and y like
latitude and longitude and this axis is
the frequency of the snip so here it's
like a flat surface it's basically the
same thing across the landscape right
like they all have a they're fixed it's
it's conserved or maybe it's under
balancing selection or something it
might just be a random change like an
isolation by distance change so you'd
expect like a sort of gradual slope
across the landscape moving
from one ecological moving from one part
of landscape to the other or you may
have these abrupt thresholds these
abrupt genetic changes in the landscape
in these snips so in one part of the
landscape you have say the all a and the
other part of landscape you have all T
and if you have these abrupt abrupt
thresholds that's an indication there's
something more interesting going on with
that snip and what you'd expect is the
vast majority of snips would look like
this across the landscape and then some
small subset would look like this and
those are ones that are potentially
involved in local adaptation so there's
this new spatial ancestry analysis that
calculates a score like a composite
score for how spatially structured a
snip is across a landscape and these are
for those hundred thousand snips each
dot is one snip what you find is the
vast majority have very low scores so
there's no clear geographic structure or
it's a gradual change well then there's
this small number up here that with very
high support exhibit this threshold so
you have one snip over here and then a
quick drop off and it's a different snip
in a different part of the landscape so
those are interesting parts of the
genome to look at for potential
selection going on so give you an idea
of what one of these looks like in
practice so again this is latitude and
longitude these graphs are not as nice
because I did them myself in our and I'm
not that good at it and then here's the
% t so if you wrote they rotate this
around you can see up here it's very
high percent and then it drops off
quickly in that part of the landscape so
we can start generating candidate
regions of the genome that show a really
stark signature across the landscape and
our next steps and I want to talk to
some folks here today about this is
trying to actually see if we can build a
model or an index of urbanization that
explains the patterns of genome-wide
variation in this data set and we have
one idea now that we're working with we
also want to look instead of just
looking at spatial structure look at the
ecology so are the ecological
associations between those snips with
this index of urbanization with deer
with tick-borne diseases something like
that and then
more classic tests for selection in this
data set to find outliers and and
finally just to end up i wanted to talk
a bit about my grad suit and stephen
Harris's work on coding regions where
he's already looking at singers of
selection in genes that make proteins
the idea being those are kind of like
potential low-hanging fruit where if you
have some some clear signatures
selection those are good candidates for
follow-up functional study for local
adaptation in the city and so way to
think about this maybe is this you know
are the country mouse in the city mouse
different i resisted that for a long
time but everyone kept bringing it up so
i just went with it and i don't know to
what extent folks here are working with
genomic data but just to give you an
idea of how you would collect these data
to make sure your sampling genes so one
way you could do is just take advantage
of the central dogma so you have DNA and
it's transcribed into RNA and if it's a
messenger RNA it probably makes a
protein right so that's why the
messenger RNA is transcribed so what you
can do is you can capture the messenger
RNA or all of the RNA and then enrich it
for the messenger RNA convert it back to
DNA and sequence that and then instead
of sequencing all the genome your
sequencing the small percentage ten
percent or whatever that is making
proteins and that may have an more
easily identifiable function in the
organism and so Steven along with Rachel
and the University of Connecticut has
been working on reference transcriptomes
for this species and for our populations
and he initially started with 454 and
has about three million reads from there
from multiple tissues liver brain ovary
and test asst the idea you use different
tissues because different genes are
expressed in different places of the
organism so you can capture more of the
diversity and jeans and then he also has
about a billion good reads from a short
read technology called solid those are
about 75 base for as long as are longer
the idea is if you have these longer
reads it can anchor your assembly so you
can find longer chunks of genes and then
use these short reads to fill them in
and
his latest assembly overall assembly has
about 40,000 almost 41,000 contigs a lot
of those are short but there are a lot
of good long ones the N 50s about a
thousand base pairs the average
mammalian gene i think is about two
thousand base pairs and he's identified
about a hundred thousand snips in that
data set and this was this data set is
derived from three urban and three rural
populations with eight individuals from
each population scania these are those
populations so three new york city
populations and three of these that
represent potential ancestral variation
in new york city peromyscus is has some
benefits for this sort of thing because
they're rodent so you can annotate your
gene sequences with information from
other rodents and most of our
information on you know what gene it is
and what it does comes from the golden
hamster which is also cry seated rodents
so they're fairly closely related and
then the lab mouse and the lab rat and
human to some extent has given us gives
us a lot of information to on what these
genes are what they do he as a was
interested in whether you could use
snips from protein coding regions to
look at population structure as well and
turns out you can and these are mostly
putative ly neutral snips and not ones
that show signatures of selection
there's a pretty clear split between the
rural populations and the urban
populations what's interesting if you
what's actually more supported is this
scenario where all of the rural
populations are mixed together but then
each of the urban populations is a
distinct population this unfortunately
makes it more difficult to interpret
signatures of selection because you may
actually even have these population each
individual urban populations with their
own local adaptations not a just an
urban adaptation he hasn't finished the
Senior Service election stuff on the big
data set this is just for the 454 data
set where he looked at the ratio of
nonsynonymous to synonymous snips in the
genes the idea here is that when you get
a base pair
change in a gene that changes the amino
acid that's usually bad right because it
messes up the protein it doesn't do its
supposed to do but if you get a lot of
those changes it's likely that that has
been selected for because otherwise the
protein would have been disabled or
altered in some negative way for the
organism so if you have a lot of these
nonsense changes that's a gene that may
be under selection so he identified a
handful that had a high ratio and they
generally fit our expectations based on
those hypotheses at the beginning for
what sorts of things would be involved
here so there were a number that were
involved in xenobiotic metabolisms they
read their proteins that respond to
compounds from outside the organism
there's one involved spermatogenesis
demethylation and then some more sorted
general stuff that these are going to be
hard to interpret once we have the
broader data set with better candidates
we're going to go back and choose some
of these as functional candidates for a
lot of further follow-up investigation
to try to figure out exactly what they
do for the organism in an urban
environment so I'm just going to skip
that for now so what are the next steps
that that nonce nas ratio test is kind
of like a crude old way of looking at
selection still works but he's gonna be
doing much more powerful test for
selection and we're going to be taking
advantage of the new genome for this
group he's doing demographic modeling in
a program called dottie to look at some
of the deeper to infer some of the
deeper demographic history of these
populations which will also help us
distinguish when you really have true
cases of selection and that previous
slide was some gene expression results
when we collected these mice we weren't
envisioning a gene expression experiment
so it's hard to say that we had clear
differences in expression which is
something you can get from these kinds
of sequencing experiments so he may run
a gene expression experiment either with
mice in the field or in the lab soon all
right so to conclude overall for what we
found from white-footed mice there there
seems to be fairly substantial genetic
structure created by urban fragmentation
and there have been a couple other labs
working on this that decided to do
similar studies there's one ongoing
study in tulsa oklahoma and there's one
in the montreal area south of montreal
where you have Lyme disease starting to
emerge and they're finding some similar
results although not the genetic
structure is not nearly as high but they
still exhibit the structure clink New
York City is a particularly isolated
environment but it's not you can't
easily predict the amount of structure
or levels genetic variation from
characteristics of parks there's not a
clear this is something we did
potentially to the parks apart was very
interested in this kind of information
but I think their parks are all too
similar you know they're all there isn't
a wide range in size or Abbott at or
anything like that in contrast there
were we're very successful at explaining
connectivity so gene flow in the city
with those models and that's something
you could take advantage of from an
urban planning standpoint so if you
wanted to create corridors it all I
would make the point these models were
just for white-footed mice and other
people have made the point we don't want
wife it's running around New York City
because they're carriers of disease but
it turns out they actually don't really
has their own a lot of ticks in the city
or any in many places they're not really
a disease concern any more so than any
other mammal but you could take
advantage of this to either breakdown or
create corridors for other species and
we're working on models for other
species stream salamanders coyotes and a
few other things that more people want
to move around in the city than
white-footed mice the connectivity
between these populations is low but you
could probably reverse that in a lot of
cases by creating more green corridors
if you if you green to this city in an
intentional way I think would be fairly
possible once you New York City has a
fairly good density of medium to large
sized parks where we sampled so you
could you could connect those in a lot
of interesting ways if you wanted to it
does seem that there is this genome-wide
structure I didn't actually show much of
this but there is less standing genetic
variation as you get in
to the city that's associated with
urbanization but we want to do a lot
more work to figure out the ecology and
landscape properties that influence
standing joma creation that's kind of
where we're at now with that project and
then we have preliminary evidence that
some protein coding genes are under
selection in urban environments but
again that's a big area of work that is
ongoing and should be finished in the
next year or so so I don't want to go on
too much longer I had some other stuff
at the end here about other species but
I'm talking to a lot of you individually
about lyst vc so i'm just going to stop
there and I'd be happy to take any
questions and I'll be around for the
afternoon so for thank you